[Music]
the newest overwatch hero is upon this
and once again it's another healer in
blizzards not-so-subtle attempt to make
people play support characters they've
given us another hero that can both dish
out damage and also mitigated and her
name is Bridget ah yes that is how it's
pronounced I'll give you all a rundown
of how to play overwatch this brand new
melee focused healer and you'll be
swinging your way to victory in no time
so raise your flag high and let's get
going
[Music]
being a healer and overwatch is tough
work thankfully brick eats a specialty
is a passive heal known as inspire for
every time you hit an enemy with your
rocket play all melee attack you'll be
healing your allies within the 20 meter
radius if you stop attacking you stop
healing so for all you aggressive battle
mercy mains out there Brigitta is the
real offensive focus support we've all
been waiting for
you're gonna be up in the frontlines
with your fellow Reinhardt's Road hogs
divas Winston's but don't worry you have
other tools to help you survive such as
her whip shot this attack shoots out the
chain portion of her flail sending it
for 20 meters and knock you back anyone
that it hits it reaches the same
distance as Road hogs hook and travels
just as fast so if you've had practice
with that you should feel right at home
with the whip shot
[Applause]
if you like knocking people around while
Brigitte has also got her shield bash
holding alternate fire will first bring
up her barrier shield which is
essentially a narrower more mobile
version of Rhinehart's think of it more
like a personal shield that you might
use to protect one enemy at a time
anyway if you have that active you can
hit your primary fire to dash forward a
bit and stun whoever's in front of you
you can use it to create space put the
brakes on someone chasing your teammate
or even interrupt Ultimates and much
like Torbjorn Brigitta also supplies
armor with a repair pack though it works
slightly different from her father's if
your target has taken damage the repair
pack will heal them to full and then
provide them with additional armor and
if they're already at full health it'll
just give them 75 armor the armor will
fade after 5 seconds and combined with
the 6 second cooldown on the ability
you'll want to pick your targets wisely
at times oh and the repair pack is
homing so you don't need to worry about
throwing a bunch on the ground then
having them be forgotten by your whole
team finally for all you world of
warcraft paladin's out there you'll want
to gather your teammates up and push
forward with bring Keats's ultimate
rally activating rally will increase
your movement speed and provide allies
around you with a 30 armor per second
buff for 10 seconds with a maximum of
150 armor unlike her repair pack though
the armor is permanent and will last
until gets taken off by damage you want
to use rally to push forward whacking
enemies with your flail since the buff
will keep giving your teammates armor
throughout the 10 seconds even if they
take damage
so just to recap plain as brigitta means
it will be up in the frontlines with
your team's tanks getting hits in to
heal them shielding yourself from damage
tossing out armor packs of people in
need and shield bashing and whip shot in
anyone that gets too close for comfort
similar to doom fists you can combo your
abilities to deal some good damage and
heal your teammates in the process using
your shield bash and then immediately
the whip shot will cause a healthy
amount of knock back and send your
opponent flying hopefully off a cliff if
you're lucky
however since Brigitte says mobility is
somewhat limited you'll want to avoid
snipers and any other hero that can take
advantage of you putting your shield
down such as a junk rat or far up also
Sombra our hack will take away
everything you've ever known and loved
so be careful and while it may be fun to
swing wildly at the other team and trust
me it is you'll want to also take extra
care when you melee since brigita lacks
the automatic health restoration that
some other support heroes have she's
best grouped with another support but if
your solo healing and find yourself low
on health you want to back up with your
barrier shield in find yourself a health
pack quick
so there's your rundown of Brisas
abilities and some tips to help you get
started using the hybrid healer she's a
lot of fun to play and bound to change
people's minds about support characters
if you've got any other tips for people
playing Brigitta leave them in the
comments below and don't forget to check
out all our hero guides for the other
overwatch characters that's 26 other
videos to get through but hey by the end
of this year you should be able to watch
one of them every day for an entire
month
so thanks for watching and keep an eye
out for more overwatch coverage on
GameSpot calm
[Music]